leave motivation watch a top 10 would
believe nation hates Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to
spend time with yourself find your
purpose and aim to be wealthy with
dhandapani and my take on his top ten
rules of success volume 3 enjoy
ok let's kick it off with rule number 1
stay narrow and deep talk a lot about
focus and I think you know one thing
I've learned you know having lived here
in New York and having my own business
is that opportunity is one of the
greatest distractions in the world I
agree totally is if your opportunity is
not aligned with your purpose then it's
a major distraction when I left the
monastery and I started building my
business ahead and once it started grow
I had so many opportunities coming my
way people that wanted to partner and do
things and new projects and I was all
excited and I said like I can do all of
this and I remember speaking at an event
in Toronto the mastermind talks with
Jeffrey and Jason gave out grants man
there was a gentleman that spoke Denmark
Eko and after he spoke at the event we
were backstage and I asked him this was
a few years after I left in Austria I
said Mach and he had built a
billion-dollar business from nothing
yeah echo yeah and I asked him I said
hey if you had one piece of
entrepreneurial advice to give an
ex-monk
was learning to be an entrepreneur what
would it be he said these was stained
air or in deep and I love that that's
become my mantra stayed narrow and deep
leases as you start to grow and scale
you find so many opportunities coming
your way but if they're not aligned
don't take them
rule number two spend time with yourself
and if I wanted to get to know you and
Christopher Lee well I have to spend
time with both of you
so just say if I lived in Hamburg and
every week we went out to dinner or
lunch and
and two hours with you make sure stuff
then after the three of us would get to
know each other very well because every
week is spending two hours with me you
know what I like what I don't like when
I'm cranky when I'm upset what makes me
happy
most people never spend any time with
themselves so how would they know what
they want in life right so the only way
I can get to know someone is by spending
time with them right so if you ask
someone how much time they spend with
yourself most people say they don't
spend any time to say oh when I walk the
dog that's when I spend time
that's my alone time I said no that's
you walking the dog because on one hand
you're walking your dog and then on the
other hand you probably like on your
phone yeah if you live in New York you
avoiding traffic you know try not to get
run over and so if some people say when
I go to the gym that's my alone time no
you're lifting weights you can't call
that a long time when I say a long time
I mean sitting down in your home quietly
no headphones no music no nothing your
eyes closed maybe sitting cross-legged
on the floor if you can if not sitting
on a chair and just going inside and
asking yourself questions having a
conversation and people say oh I don't
have time for that but it's so
fascinating right
if someone all I say that people spend
five minutes with yourself every morning
having a conversation the same way I
would have a conversation with you and
your husband but people say they don't
have time but if their friend calls them
up and say hey do you want to go out for
dinner
they'll say sure let's go out for dinner
and they'll spend two hours with their
friend having dinner but they don't have
time for themselves do you know how many
five minutes they are in two hours just
twenty four five minutes segments that
means you can sit with yourself every
day for five minutes for twenty four
days straight
if you skip dinner people will make time
for other people but they won't make
time for themselves rule number three
find your purpose that's in general most
people
siliceous and that's something that I
get quite often that people come up with
me with a lack of clarity know what they
want to do in their life
yeah it's really interesting I was
sitting with a group of entrepreneurs
heavy without traveling around the world
recently enough to my event that you
know dinner I'm gonna sitting with four
guys at the table having dinner and
we're having a glass of wine and I just
asked the question
what's he a purpose in life yeah and
nobody could answer me all our spirits
yep
I love it a lot to me what's your
purpose in life so is there a way we can
find our purpose in some way I know it's
a hard question yeah no I mean their way
squeeze it into a video but yeah I think
you know I think one of the questions I
get off on a spec when I ask that
question is do you even need a purpose
in life you know we every day we have a
goal we I mean you have bathrooms as a
perpetrator bathroom there's a purpose
because you want to eat something or
drink something they don't cut something
yeah so our days full with some purpose
another so it's great to have purpose in
life the main reason for having purpose
in life is so that you can focus your
energy towards one thing and it doesn't
get distracted when you know what you
want you know what you don't want yeah
and that's the greatest gift because
then you can say no very easily you know
what kind of guy to say no to if you're
dating we got a girl to say no to
yeah cuz you just know this is not what
I want more people say yes to everything
and everyone in their life
they don't know what they want so
figuring out your purpose is really
really important and I don't say to even
begin that process spend five minutes a
day with yourself every day in a silent
reflection that would be a great way to
stuff find a quiet spot in your house
sit down for five minutes and just no
phones no books you know a notepad is
nothing just you and ask yourself what
do you want in life rule number four aim
to be wealthy you talked about you know
having a business and can we also then
pursue spirituality and one of the big
things you know in the four goals wealth
you notice is the second one a lot of
times people say to me that you know if
you're on a spiritual path you shouldn't
be pursuing wealth my money in
spirituality don't go hand in hand and
it's actually a concept that in the
philosophy I subscribe to it's not what
it's preached one of the goals actually
as household is to be as wealthy as
possible and that's why they call wealth
this right and then next to love right
so it's love wealth Dharma and
enlightened and the goal the concept
here is that if you're wealthy then you
can look after your family you can meet
all your needs which is part of your
Dharma doing your duty to your family
you can also then healthy community and
impact the world it's the only way you
can impact the world is if you have
resources to do so
right right if you had no money how
could you go out and impact the wall
mm-hmm
you know how can you clean up the oceans
how can you help schools or often it
doesn't feed the poor you can't you need
both so the the acquisition of the
wealth is is really important and a lot
of times people you know especially with
one I do the people look at me as a
Hindu priests I'm dressed up this way
they see I have an online course they
see me speaking they're kind of like oh
I see making money off spirituality and
I'm like mm-hmm
why is money of that thing mm-hmm you
know people look at money as a bad thing
but it's not a bad thing and it depends
on what you do with it mm-hmm but you
can pursue a life of acquiring wealth
and scaling and growing that wealth and
yet still pursue the spiritual life how
do you use that wealth that's a
different question
all
if you want more motivation and
self-love checking my 254 series they're
free the link to join are in the
description below no one on planet earth
can stop you from accomplishing and
achieving what you want it's easy to
make a buck very hard to make a
difference the quality of your life is
essentially determined by how you carry
this one yes or no rule number five a
value life I want you your life and you
realize and I always say that life is
finite you know life is not short but
there's a clear definitive end and once
you realize that life once you realize
that life is finite then you start to
make choices you start to realize what
is important I have one life I don't get
a second shot at this how do I want to
live my life rule number six develop
your concentration and willpower grab
that ball that ball of light that
awareness and consciously move it to any
area of the mind that you want to go to
and if somebody or something is pulling
that awareness to an area of the mind
that you don't want to go to you use
your willpower and your powers of
concentration to bring awareness back to
your present moment or to wherever it is
you are that that point in time so the
two things we want to learn how to
develop is the powers of concentration
and our willpower how do we develop
concentration let's define what
concentration is first I'd like to
define concentration as the ability to
keep your awareness on one thing for an
extended period of time
so that ball of light if you can hold it
on one thing for an extended period of
time
you're concentrating but if you allow
your awareness to jump from one thing to
another all the time without any control
then you're being distracted rule number
seven visualize what is visualization
let's define it visualization is the
conscious exercising of the power of
thought to create mental images that
help create and design the future right
so you're exercising the power of
thought so you can create mental images
that can help manifest and design your
future it's important to know that
everything begins in the mental plane
first before it manifests in the
physical plane we think about something
first and then we start to create
the physical plane rule number eight
believe in yourself believe in yourself
believe in your ability to create one of
the greatest ways to overcome fear in
life is to know that you actually have
the ability to create and manifest
things in your life you truly do and in
order to create and manifest something
in your life you have to understand how
your mind works because once you can
understand how your mind works you can
control it once you can control it you
can direct it and you can use the powers
of concentration that you develop to
focus in on what you want and when you
focus your awareness on something that's
where your energy is flowing and that's
what starts to manifest in your life so
once you start believing in your power
to create proceed with confidence rule
number nine find your path in life and
remember going to my cousin's house for
a birthday party and you know my
brothers and I are really excited about
it and parents are you know so we're
gonna go this evening and so we're
waiting all day to go to the potty and
then we get a car that drives us over
there you know we that was the creation
bottle of it and then we go on the
experience and with the birthday party
and eating cake and playing with
balloons and my cousins and I'm getting
the car drive home and I remember
looking out the window and going that's
it it's over everything so what's the
constant in life you know mom sister you
gonna take us out for ice cream tonight
and so we're all excited all day talking
about what flavor ice cream we're gonna
get there we go out and get ice cream
and enjoy it and then it's only brown
people they live and then they die and
it's over something like what the heck
you know I mean what's what's the
continent like what is what is it in
life that does not change and is that
what underpinned your your search and
wanting to become a mug what is the
constant right exactly what is this I
just couldn't I couldn't accept the fact
that life was just that those three
stages of creation experiencing and then
watching it all just go away so there
must be something deeper to it and I
found that the monastic path was the
most efficient way to finding that
answer you know
could have gone off and become an
engineer and done all that stuff but it
wouldn't be an efficient way to try and
find what I was looking for so that's
why I joined the monastry annual number
ten the last one before a very special
bonus clip is improve your productivity
I think you know with the with
technology in the work space I think
there are no guidelines right people
people don't set up guidelines one of
the things I talk about you know when I
work with companies and then my
cultivating focus is that there's no way
to tell someone in the work space
especially if you have an open floor
open plan for a plan that what's your
status right now so for example do you
Skype or have you Skype Skype before
well you can set your status as offline
busy on a call not available right and
when you see someone who's offline
most of the time I think most people
will never try calling that person if
they offline or they're not available or
it says do not disturb you don't try and
call that person right but in the work
space in an open floor open plan floor
plan there's no way to set that service
there's no way to inform so what happens
if someone is working on the computer
they might be doing accounting trying to
solve some complex accounting issue and
then someone comes up to them and goes
hey John do you know where the photocopy
paper is so now he goes oh it used to be
in this cupboard I think they moved it
over there you know have a look over
there because I know thank you so that
guy goes to get the photocopy paper that
John goes back to his accounting and
he's lost his train of thought you know
his awareness was so deep in it trying
to solve something complex and now his
awareness moved to the person to talk
about photocopy paper and now he comes
back and he has to try and get back to
where he was and he may not and if
specially if you're doing something
creative I remember working with a
fashion company in LA and they said the
same thing you know their designers
sketching the Fall collection someone
comes and ask them a question or says hi
they tend they say hello
they tend back to continue to sketch and
now they've lost
the Mojo gave us a flow so because
there's no way for the person working to
tell that person what their status is so
one simple solution I tell companies is
to have a simple flag like you drive on
the street there's traffic lights red
means stop orange or yellow means go
faster no
prepare the stop right and green means
go so what if you had a little flag on
your desk this as an example yeah it
doesn't have to be a plane but you have
a little plastic flag on you and you say
red means do not disturb me I am in less
than something really important but what
you do is within the department to say
if you're under design department of the
accounting department there's ten people
in the accounting department all ten
people have a meeting and we set the
status as red means do not disturb but
below it we outlined the conditions upon
which you can interrupt so if the
building is on fire yes you can disturb
me and let me know all right if these
conditions are not met you don't disturb
me then if it's an orange flag then you
can say okay I'm doing something
important but it's not super important
so there's any if these conditions are
met you can interrupt me and if I have a
green flag means I'm just working if you
want to come by and say hello do you
want to interrupt me it's fine so that
way someone walking will see a flag and
go like oh it's a red flag
I shouldn't disturb that person now you
increase productivity and efficiency in
the workplace because there is a way to
inform other people in the workspace
what your status is now I have a special
bonus gift from dhandapani on how to
meditate that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
where do you need to improve your
productivity number two how can you
believe in yourself more and number
three how will you spend more time with
yourself this week and if you promise to
take action after watching this video we
don't just watch videos anymore we do
something after watching them
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments
make that promise to yourself and then
get to work preparation is key it is
really important to prepare for your
meditation the same way if you had an
important guest coming to your home and
you wanted to welcome them you would
prepare your home you clean your home
you would place flowers you would maybe
cook some really nice food and prepare
to welcome the guests on the same way an
athlete or performer might prepare
warm-up before they go on stage on the
field to compete deeper past well it's
so important to prepare as well when we
meditate preparation is key for
meditation and if you prepare well you
will meditate extremely well
if you want more dine upon a check out
the first top 10 rules I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
a monk that tells you he's never
questioned the path or never thought of
leaving is like - we live our lives like
we're going to live forever but the
truth is we don't live forever